As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal. And with seven rewards, I'm just $4.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡肉三明治，人们总是说我声音很大。而我会想，对啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你期望我窃窃私语吗？如果你想要安静，去吃点汤并反思一下吧。就像，我知道我很难应付。我很豪爽，很多汁。给我加上一些酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一整顿饭。而且只要有7-Eleven奖励积分，我只要4美元。
Quiet. No. Crispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 36-2326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. PMS, or premenstrual syndrome, has long been the subject of tired, sexist jokes and stereotypes about moody and irrational women.
安静？才不。又脆、很多汁而且只要4美元？非常可以。仅限7-Eleven。地区代码36-2326，仅限参与门店，售完即止。详情请看全称。经前期综合征（PMS）长期以来一直是那些针对情绪化和不理性女性的陈旧、性别歧视笑话和刻板印象的主题。
But psychologists who study hormones in the brain say that these stereotypes are wrong on several counts. First, for most people who menstruate, the menstrual cycle doesn't cause significant changes in mood or behavior. At the same time, a small percentage of people do experience severe premenstrual symptoms. Now researchers are working to better understand what those symptoms are and how the menstrual cycle interacts with mental health. In 2013, a new syndrome premenstrual dysphoric disorder was added to the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. Today we're going to talk about what that is and how common it is. What do we know about the causes of PMDD?
但研究大脑荷尔蒙的心理学家表示，这些刻板印象在好几个方面都是错误的。首先，对于大多数有月经周期的人来说，月经周期并不会引起情绪或行为的显著变化。与此同时，确实有一小部分人会经历严重的经前期症状。现在，研究人员正在努力更好地理解这些症状是什么，以及月经周期如何与心理健康相互作用。2013年，一个新的综合征——经前期烦躁障碍（PMDD）被加入到《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中。今天我们将讨论那是什么，以及它有多常见。我们对PMDD的成因了解多少？
Who is most at risk and what treatments are available? What are scientists learning about how hormones, and mental health interact? What role does the menstrual cycle play for some people in suicidality and mental health disorders? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Tori Eisenhower Mao, an associate professor of psychiatry and psychology at the University of Illinois at Chicago. She's a clinical psychologist, and scientists who studies the effects of the menstrual cycle on emotions, thought patterns,
谁受到的风险最大？有哪些可用的治疗方法？科学家们关于荷尔蒙与心理健康如何相互作用学到了什么？对于某些人来说，月经周期在自杀倾向和心理健康障碍中扮演了什么角色？欢迎收听“心理学谈话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校的精神病学和心理学副教授托丽·艾森豪威尔·毛（Tori Eisenhower Mao）博士。她是一名临床心理学家，也是研究月经周期对情绪、思维模式影响的科学家，
and behaviors. In her lab, she and her colleagues research how hormone sensitivity interacts with problems such as emotional distress, substance use, and suicide attempts. In addition to her research, Dr. Eisenhower-Mell also treats patients with severe treatment-resistant pre-menstrual symptoms. She also chairs the Clinical Advisory Board for the International Association of Pre-Mensual disorders. Dr. Eisenhower-Mell, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. It's wonderful to be here. Let's start by talking about premenstrual dysphoric disorder, which, as I mentioned, was added to the DSM in 2013. What is PMDD and how is it different from PMS, which I think is what most people think of when they think of premenstrual syndrome. Yeah, so premenstrual dysphoria disorder is a severe
以及行为。在她的实验室里，她和她的同事们研究荷尔蒙敏感性如何与情绪困扰、物质使用和自杀企图等问题相互作用。除了研究之外，艾森豪威尔·梅尔博士还治疗患有严重、对治疗有抵抗力的经前期症状的患者。她还担任国际经前期障碍协会（International Association of Premenstrual Disorders）临床顾问委员会的主席。艾森豪威尔·梅尔博士，非常感谢你今天加入我的节目。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。让我们从讨论经前期烦躁障碍开始，正如我提到的，它在2013年被加入了DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）。什么是PMDD？它与PMS有何不同？我想PMS是大多数人在想到经前期综合征时想到的。是的，所以经前期烦躁障碍是一种严重的
emotional reaction to the normal hormonal changes of the menstrual cycle. roughly 6% of the menstruating population experiences premenstrual dysphoric disorder. In terms of its relationship to PMS, I like to say that PMS is a very broad umbrella term that has been used for so long that it started to lose meaning. It's so broad. It's been used in so many different contexts to talk about physical symptoms, emotional symptoms, and also to talk about symptoms of such varying severity where, Sometimes people are speaking of PMS as very, very mild symptoms that would not affect day-to-day life at all.
对月经周期正常荷尔蒙变化的极端情绪反应。大约6%有月经的人群会经历经前期烦躁障碍。就它与PMS的关系而言，我喜欢说PMS是一个非常宽泛的伞形术语，这个词已经被使用了太久，以至于开始失去意义。它太宽泛了。它被用在许多不同的语境中来谈论身体症状、情绪症状，以及谈论严重程度截然不同的症状，有时，人们所说的PMS是非常非常轻微的症状，根本不会影响日常生活。
And other times they're talking about very severe symptoms that really reach the threshold of an emotional disorder. And that's where we would start to think about diagnosing with premenstrual dysphoric disorder. Is there a test for PMDD? How would a person know that they have it? So the DSM-5 included a set of diagnostic criteria for pre-menstrual dysphoric disorder. The symptoms must be emotional primarily, so there has to be this core sort of psychological distress as part of the disorder. It's not necessary that the symptoms necessarily impair daily life, although they usually do. The DSM, we can talk about this more later, but the DSM is very strict in its prescription of what PMDD needs to look like.
而有时他们谈论的是非常严重的症状，确实达到了情绪障碍的阈值。这就是我们开始考虑诊断经前期烦躁障碍的时候。有没有针对PMDD的测试？一个人怎么知道自己得了这个病？所以DSM-5包含了一套针对经前期烦躁障碍的诊断标准。症状必须主要是情绪方面的，所以作为该障碍的一部分，必须有这种核心的心理痛苦。症状不一定非要损害日常生活，尽管它们通常会。DSM，我们稍后可以对此进行更多讨论，但DSM对其对PMDD外观的规定非常严格。
it requires at least one emotional symptoms and five total symptoms to show cyclical change across the menstrual cycle. And it's not just that the person needs to report these changes in an interview. Because we know that people have been culturally influenced to think that all females have PMS, we find that many, many patients report severe. premenstrual symptoms, but then when we track their symptoms across the cycle longitudinally, we don't actually see any notable change in their symptoms in the daily ratings. And so because of this, the work group that created the DSM-5 PMDD disorder actually requires two months of daily ratings of the symptoms of PMDD in order to make the diagnosis. And just for completeness,
它要求至少有一种情绪症状和总共五种症状，以显示出在月经周期内呈周期性变化。而且不仅仅是个人需要在访谈中报告这些变化。因为我们知道人们在文化上受到影响，认为所有女性都有PMS，我们发现非常多的患者报告有严重的经前期症状，但随后当我们在整个周期中对他们的症状进行纵向追踪时，我们实际上在每日评分中没有看到他们的症状有任何显著变化。正因为如此，创建DSM-5 PMDD障碍的工作组实际上要求对PMDD的症状进行两个月的每日评分，以便做出诊断。为了完整起见，
I'll ticked on through some of the specific symptoms that we're looking for. The core symptoms need to be at least one of depression, anxiety, mood swings, or rejection sensitivity, or anger and irritability. So there needs to be across the longitudinal daily ratings pattern that we see. We need to see that at least one of those core emotional symptoms are showing this pattern of symptoms being present in the pre-monthsual week and then really disappearing in the week after mencies. Now, there's a common idea that premenstrual symptoms are due to a hormonal imbalance
我将列举一些我们正在寻找的具体症状。核心症状需要至少是以下之一：抑郁、焦虑、情绪波动、或拒绝敏感性，或者是愤怒和易怒。因此，在纵向的每日评分模式中，我们需要看到这一点。我们需要看到至少其中一个核心情绪症状表现出这样一种症状模式：在经前期周出现，然后在经期后的一周内真正消失。现在，有一种普遍的观点认为经前期症状是由荷尔蒙失衡引起的
or hormone levels that are out of whack. But that's not accurate, as I understand it. I mean, what do we know about the causes of severe premenstrual symptoms? It's a great question. And it intersects with mental health stigma, which I think is really fascinating. So when we think about a disorder where the symptoms are triggered by hormone changes, we can see how many patients will assume that this is a result of something being wrong with their reproductive system, something being wrong with their hormones. And it's an understandable assumption that patients
或者是失调的荷尔蒙水平。但据我所了解，这并不准确。我的意思是，我们对严重经前期症状的原因了解多少？这是一个很好的问题。它与心理健康污名化相交织，我认为这非常迷人。因此，当我们想到一种由荷尔蒙变化引发症状的障碍时，我们可以看到许多患者会假设这是他们的生殖系统出问题、他们的荷尔蒙出问题的结果。这是一个可以理解的假设，患者们
make. And this is fueled by a lot of sort of natural health outlets and people selling natural health products to promote hormonal balance. And if that were the case, that would be fine. But unfortunately, across the past decades, we've repeatedly looked, not me specifically, but my predecessors have repeatedly looked at estrogen, progesterone, LH, other hormones across the cycle in people with and without these severe premenstrual emotional symptoms. And there's really no consistent differences between the groups. And what this suggests, along with other experimental studies that have directly manipulated hormones in these groups is that it's not anything to do with an abnormal menstrual cycle, an abnormal hormonal profile, an abnormal trajectory of hormonal
会做出这种假设。这受到许多天然健康销售渠道和销售天然健康产品以促进荷尔蒙平衡的人的推波助澜。如果真是这样，那就好了。但不幸的是，在过去的几十年里，我们一再地观察过，不是我特指，而是我的前辈们一再地在患有和未患有这些严重经前期情绪症状的人群中观察了雌激素、孕激素、黄体生成素以及周期中的其他荷尔蒙。并且在这些群体之间确实没有一致的差异。这表明，连同直接在这些群体中操纵荷尔蒙的其他实验研究一起，它与异常的月经周期、异常的荷尔蒙配置文件、异常的荷尔蒙轨迹都没有任何关系。
change, an abnormal balance between the two hormones. None of that has really panned out. It really seems that the reproductive system in people with premenstrual dysphoric disorder is absolutely normal from what we can tell so far. It even seems so far that the critical hormonal metabolites that we know mediate or provoke the symptoms of PMDD, even those appear to be the same between PMDD and controls. And so this really leaves us with one most prominent possibility, which is that the brain is abnormally sensitive to normal changes in estrogen and progesterone in this disorder.
改变，两种荷尔蒙之间的异常平衡。这些都没有真正成立。确实看起来，就我们目前所能了解到的而言，患有经前期烦躁障碍的人的生殖系统是绝对正常的。甚至到目前为止，我们知道调节或引发PMDD症状的关键荷尔蒙代谢物，即使是这些，在PMDD患者和对照组之间似乎也是相同的。因此，这确实给我们留下了一个最突出的可能性，那就是在大脑中，这种障碍对雌激素和孕激素的正常变化异常敏感。
And so there have been several really elegant experimental studies in which the reproductive system in both PMDD and controls is suppressed, and then they manipulate estrogen or progesterone to understand whether there's this abnormal sensitivity. And in fact, they do see this, that when you manipulate the hormones in those with a history of PMDD in the daily ratings, you see that this provokes symptoms, patients become distressed. And in controls, you don't see this. And so this is a nice experimental demonstration that it really is an abnormal sensitivity to normal hormonal change. Now, one more thing that I'll say about this is that this is a disappointment to many patients. And I think we really have to look to mental health stigma to understand why that is,
因此，已经进行了几项非常优雅的实验研究，其中抑制了PMDD和对照组的生殖系统，然后他们操纵雌激素或孕激素来了解是否存在这种异常敏感性。事实上，他们确实看到了这一点，当你在日常评分中操纵有PMDD病史的人的荷尔蒙时，你会发现这会引发症状，患者会感到痛苦。而在对照组中，你不会看到这一点。因此，这是一个很好的实验证明，证明这确实是对正常荷尔蒙变化的异常敏感。现在，关于这一点我还要说的另一件事是，这对许多患者来说是一个失望。我认为我们真的必须从心理健康污名化来看待为什么会这样，
right? Because if you believe that you have a disorder that is being caused by a reproductive problem or an endocrine hormonal problem, there's more of an in our society, unfortunately, there's more of a sense for most people of, this is not my fault, this is just my biology. The way that we think about mental health disorders, unfortunately in our society is very stigmatized. People think about anything to do with the brain as being more the fault of the patient and more heavily under the control of the patient, even when that's not the case. And so understandably, patients, when they learn that this is a psychiatric disorder, many of them feel that they're being blamed for their symptoms or that they're being called quote unquote crazy or quote unquote
对吧？因为如果你相信你患有一种由生殖问题或内分泌荷尔蒙问题引起的障碍，在我们的社会中，不幸的是，对于大多数人来说，会有一种感觉：“这不是我的错，这只是我的生物学问题。”不幸的是，在我们社会中，我们看待心理健康障碍的方式被严重污名化了。人们认为与大脑有关的任何事情更多是患者的错，并且更多地受患者控制，即使事实并非如此。因此，可以理解的是，当患者得知这是一种精神疾病时，他们中的许多人会觉得自己的症状受到了指责，或者他们被称作所谓的“疯子”或者所谓的
hysterical. When that's really not the case, we think of it as, you know, what is happening in the brain that's creating this abnormal sensitivity. But you can understand for a patient, you know, they're not quite thinking on that level. Many of them steeped in the mental health stigma that we have in our world, in our country, really see that as threatening. And so there really is a desire on the part of many of the patients to think. of this as a hormone imbalance or something really that could be fixed through changing the hormones. And that's understandable, but it's also wrong. And I think we have to tear down the mental health stigma in order to then address the brain issue that's happening here.
“歇斯底里”。而事实并非如此，我们认为这是：大脑中发生了什么导致了这种异常敏感。但你可以理解一个患者，你知道，他们没有在那个水平上思考。他们许多人沉浸在我们世界、我们国家存在的心理健康污名化中，真的认为这是一种威胁。因此，许多患者确实有一种渴望，想要将其视为荷尔蒙失衡或可以通过改变荷尔蒙来真正解决的问题。这是可以理解的，但这也是错误的。我认为我们必须打破心理健康污名化，才能解决这里正在发生的大脑问题。
It sounds a little bit like an autoimmune problem. Is there a relationship between other autoimmune situations and what happens in PMDD? There have been a few studies on immune function in PMDD versus controls, not many. So far, there don't appear, the data that I have seen, there don't appear to be massive differences in the periphery. That doesn't mean that there isn't some kind of neuroimmune mechanism at play, so there could be some kind of activity, abnormal activity of hormones interacting with the immune system in the brain. However, I think that the stronger evidence has to do with the effects of individual differences in sensitivity to these hormones at the level of some neurotransmitter systems.
这听起来有点像自身免疫问题。其他自身免疫情况与PMDD中发生的事情之间有什么关系吗？关于PMDD与对照组免疫功能的研究有几项，但不多。到目前为止，似乎并没有，根据我见过的数据，外周似乎没有巨大的差异。这并不意味着某种神经免疫机制没有在起作用，所以可能会有某种活动，荷尔蒙在大脑中与免疫系统相互作用的异常活动。然而，我认为更有力的证据与这些荷尔蒙敏感性的个体差异在某些神经递质系统水平上的影响有关。
There's some evidence that, you know, serotonin is differentially, more greatly impacted in folks with PMDD in the ludial phase. We know that SSRIs are very effective for a lot of people, but really at this point, it's early days, and we have a lot of work to do, both to understand the primary biology of PMDD and also maybe some of the variants around PMDD that could be triggered by slightly different mechanisms. What treatments are available for people who are suffering from severe premenstrual symptoms and where can they go for treatment and do you start, say, with your general practitioner, your physician, do you go to a psychologist or a psychiatrist, do you talk to your OBGYN? I mean, where do you start?
有一些证据表明，你知道，血清素在黄体期的PMDD患者中受到的影响不同且更大。我们知道SSRIs（选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂）对很多人非常有效，但实际上在这一点上，还处于早期阶段，我们有很多工作要做，既要了解PMDD的主要生物学特性，也要了解可能由略微不同的机制引发的PMDD的一些变体。对于遭受严重经前期症状困扰的人有哪些可用的治疗方法？他们可以去哪里寻求治疗？你从哪里开始，比如说，从你的全科医生、医师开始，还是去找心理学家或精神科医生，还是和你的妇产科医生交谈？我的意思是，你从哪里开始？
Yeah. So when evaluating symptoms, it's really important to track symptoms across the cycle. And I would say that if you have the time to track your symptoms across a couple of cycles even before you see a physician, if you have that luxury, I would do that because it really helps the provider, whoever you see, to understand the pattern of symptoms that you have and whether you would qualify for treatment. There's a major lag in the training of medical providers in the evidence-based treatment of pre-mensual dysphoric disorder. And so what I would say is that you should start, if you're having these symptoms, you should start with whoever you're most comfortable with and whoever you think is going to listen to you when you bring this up. I would say a primary care provider, you know, a general practitioner is fine. I would say an OB-Gyne is fine, a psychiatrist is fine, but it really should be somebody that
是的。因此，在评估症状时，跨周期追踪症状真的很重要。我想说的是，如果你有时间在看医生之前甚至在几个周期中追踪你的症状，如果你有这种奢侈条件，我会这样做，因为它真的有助于医疗提供者——无论你看到谁——了解你的症状模式以及你是否有资格接受治疗。医疗提供者在循证治疗经前期烦躁障碍方面的培训存在严重滞后。所以我想说的是，你应该开始，如果你有这些症状，你应该从你最感舒适的人开始，以及你认为当你提出这一点时会倾听你的人开始。我会说初级保健提供者，你知道，全科医生是可以的。我会说妇产科医生是可以的，精神科医生是可以的，但它真的应该是一个人
you're comfortable with. At the end of the day, it's still true that the majority of health care providers are not aware of this new disorder yet, and so unfortunately, the reality is that patients really are going to be doing a bit of education of their providers in many cases, that this is a real disorder, and that it does require treatment. What I often recommend is that patients print off some of the online resources about it and educate themselves about how the disorder is treated so that they can understand whether their provider is proceeding along an evidence-based science-backed path or not. So let me talk about what that looks like. So first, SSRIs are the number one treatment. They beat placebo very consistently in pre-monthrial dysphoric
你觉得舒服的人。归根结底，绝大多数医疗提供者仍然不知道这种新疾病，所以不幸的是，现实情况是，在许多情况下，患者确实需要对他们的提供者进行一些教育，让他们知道这是一种真正的疾病，并且确实需要治疗。我经常建议的是，患者打印出一些关于它的在线资源，并自我教育该疾病是如何治疗的，以便他们能够了解他们的提供者是否走在循证、科学支持的道路上。所以让我谈谈那是什么样子的。首先，SSRIs是首选疗法。在经前期烦躁障碍中，它们非常持续地战胜了安慰剂
disorder. They also beat placebo from what we can tell very rapidly. They seem to work after about 24 hours, which is much faster than we see them beating placebo in other disorders. And so this potentially suggests that there's a different mechanism of action for the efficacy of SSRIs in PMDD. It may be, in contrast to some of the other disorders, that there is sort of a straightforward serotonergic buffering mechanism where there's alter. We know that there's poorer serotonergic function in the ludial phase of the menstrual cycle when progesterone is high in PMDD. And so SSRIs may be pretty rapidly effective in buffering that. So we generally recommend that people start with trying one and maybe even two or three SSRIs before moving on to other things because they do very consistently
就我们所能了解的来看，它们战胜安慰剂的速度也非常快。它们似乎在大约24小时后起作用，这比我们在其他疾病中看到它们战胜安慰剂的速度要快得多。因此，这潜在地表明SSRIs在PMDD中的疗效存在不同的作用机制。与某些其他疾病相比，可能存在一种直接的血清素缓冲机制，其中发生了改变。我们知道，当孕酮很高时，在月经周期的黄体期，PMDD患者的血清素功能较差。因此，SSRIs可能在缓冲这一方面相当迅速地有效。所以我们通常建议人们在转向其他事情之前尝试一种甚至两到三种SSRIs，因为它们非常一致。
beat placebo in clinical trials. After that, there's also slightly less robust evidence, but clinical trials evidence nonetheless that drospirinone containing oral contraceptives. So historically, the first one of these was called Yaz, but there's a few others as well. This combined oral contraceptive pill contains both ethynal estradile, like most oral contraceptives, but also a new generation of progestin called Drospirinone that is derived from a different hormone that seems to provoke fewer side effects and also seems to have some other benefits like reduced bloating and some things like that. So that is usually the second line.
在临床试验中表现优于安慰剂。此后，还有一些证据虽不够那么扎实，但同样来自临床试验，表明含有屈螺酮（drospirenone）的口服避孕药有效。历史上，这类药物的第一个叫优思明（Yaz），不过也有其他几种。这种复合口服避孕药既含有炔雌醇（与大多数口服避孕药一样），也含有新一代的孕激素——屈螺酮，它源自另一种激素，似乎能引发更少的副作用，并且似乎还有一些其他益处，比如减轻腹胀等。所以这通常是第二线治疗。
Often what we'll see is that people will have some relief with SSRIs and then they will add the combined oral contraceptive. I do think it's important to note that other combined oral contraceptives that contain other progestins, so not drospirinone, but some of the other ones, those have not beat placebo in clinical trials, and they have been tested. So it does seem that there may be something special about this particular oral contraceptive or family of contraceptives that contain drospirinone. We're not 100% sure why they work better, but that is the next step. And so both of those are FDA-approved for the treatment of PMDD. Often we'll see people do SSRIs and then add an oral contraceptive or switch to an oral contraceptive. If those treatments have
我们通常看到的情况是，人们在使用SSRIs获得一些缓解后，会加用复合口服避孕药。我认为有必要指出的是，含有其他孕激素（即非屈螺酮，而是其他某些孕激素）的其他复合口服避孕药，在临床试验中并未战胜安慰剂，尽管它们接受过测试。因此，这种特殊的口服避孕药或含有屈螺酮的避孕药家族确实似乎有其特殊之处。我们并非百分之百确定它们为何效果更好，但这正是下一步。这两者都获得了FDA批准用于治疗PMDD。通常我们会看到人们先使用SSRIs，然后再加用口服避孕药，或者转换为口服避孕药。如果这些治疗
not worked and the symptoms are still very distressing and impairing, then we would recommend seeing usually an OB-guine to discuss the possibility of what we call chemical menopause. And it sounds very severe, but it's actually a fully temporary, reversible menopausal state. So you give usually an injection of a medication that suppresses activity of the ovaries, and it basically puts you into a month-long menopausal state. And then what we would do is we would add back stable levels of estrogen and progesterone so that we, you know, protect the patient against menopausal symptoms and also some of the risks associated with low estrogen. And so really the goal is to create a stable level of the hormones at roughly the same level
没有效果，且症状仍然非常痛苦和具有破坏性，那么我们通常会建议去看妇产科医生，讨论我们所称的“药物性绝经”的可能性。听起来可能很严重，但这其实是一个完全临时且可逆的绝经状态。你通常会注射一种抑制卵巢功能的药物，它基本上会让你进入一个持续一个月的绝经状态。接着，我们会做的是补回稳定水平的雌激素和孕激素，这样我们就能（你知道的）保护患者免受绝经症状以及与低雌激素相关的一些风险的影响。所以真正的目标是以大约相同的水平创建一个稳定的激素水平，
that the patient would be experiencing normally, but without the fluctuations that we know trigger the symptoms. And so we recently, my laboratory recently published a really practical guide, how to guide for the use of GNRH agonis in the treatment of PMDD to generate agonists are the medications that are used to provoke this chemical menopause. So we wrote out of a very detailed explanation in the hopes
即患者平时会经历的水平，但去除了我们所知的会触发症状的波动。最近，我的实验室发表了一份非常实用的指南，即关于在PMDD治疗中使用GnRH激动剂的操作指南。GnRH激动剂是用于诱发这种药物性绝经的药物。因此，我们写下了非常详细的解释，希望
that perhaps reproductive psychiatrists would learn to do this as well because that's often where patients are going. Of course, OBGygines also use these medications for other things, but they're not typically as aware of PMDD. So we have the situation where the OB-Egyne know how to use the medication, but the psychiatrists know about the disorder.
生殖精神科医生也许也能学会如何使用它，因为这往往是患者去看病的地方。当然，妇产科医生也会将这些药物用于其他事情，但他们通常对PMDD没有那么了解。所以我们遇到了这样一种情况：妇产科医生知道如何使用该药物，而精神科医生了解这种疾病。
And so, you know, there's sort of this mismatch, right? So we've been working on trying to increase the competence and awareness of psychiatrists in being able to offer this medication. If that does not provide relief, there are some other symptom management approaches that could be tried, you know, psychotherapy, particularly if there are other disorders happening. Evidence-based psychotherapy is certainly indicated, especially, especially if there's chronic suicidality, learning skills to keep oneself safe as you navigate the medical landscape is important. And there can be some other medications used to manage the symptoms, usually through a psychiatrist. But at that point, if symptom relief is not achieved and or the cycle's
所以（你知道的）这存在某种脱节，对吧？因此，我们一直致力于提高精神科医生提供这种药物的能力和认知。如果这不能提供缓解，还可以尝试其他一些症状管理方法，比如心理治疗，尤其是当同时发生其他障碍时。循证心理治疗当然是适用的，特别是在存在慢性自杀倾向时，学习在应对医疗环境时保护自己的技能非常重要。还可以使用一些其他药物来管理症状，通常是通过精神科医生。但如果在那个时候仍未实现症状缓解，并且/或者经期
not fully suppressed by the medication, some patients will make the drastic decision to actually have their ovaries removed and go into a surgical menopause, which then has a similar set of knees. You know, we need to add back the hormones in a stable state. But that for a lot of people is sort of the curative end point. It's not the, certainly not a common outcome, but it, but it, it's not a normal outcome, but it is, it happens for quite a few people. which speaks to how severe the symptoms must be for some people. Yes. For you to take that kind of a root which is very dire.
未能被药物完全抑制，一些患者会做出激烈的决定，切除卵巢并进入手术绝经，这随后会带来相似的一系列需求。（你知道的）我们需要以稳定状态补回激素。但对很多人来说，这算是一种治愈性的终点。它肯定不是一个常见的结局，但它……它……这不是一个常规结局，但对相当多的人来说确实发生了。这说明了对于某些人来说症状一定有多么严重。是的。让你采取那种非常极端的路线。
Typically in those situations, there is recurrent suicidality or recurrent hospitalization that really tracks with the menstrual cycle and is not resolving with this chemical menopause approach. What do we know about hormone sensitivity generally and suicidality? Yeah, so my laboratory has worked on this quite a bit in the past few years. For a long time, there was a sense that premenstrual dysphoric disorder, because it's limited to this one phase of the menstrual cycle, there was a sense among many physicians and scientists, and I was even one of these people a little bit, that, well, it's only happening for part of the time. How bad can it be at that point, right? You know, it's only going to be. last a little while and, you know, but then I spent more time with patients, especially patients who are treatment resistant, patients who did end up having surgery. And I learned pretty quickly from an anecdotal standpoint that suicidality is very common in PMDD. And one of the things that's scariest
通常在这些情况下，会出现反复的自杀倾向或反复住院，这确实与月经周期同步，并且无法通过这种药物性绝经的方法得到解决。我们对总体激素敏感性与自杀倾向了解多少？是的，所以在过去的几年里，我的实验室在这方面做相当多的研究。长期以来，人们有一种感觉，即经前期 dysphoric disorder（经前期烦躁症），因为它局限于月经周期的这一个阶段，许多医生和科学家（甚至我以前也是其中之一）曾有一种感觉，即“好吧，它只在部分时间内发生。那个时候它能有多严重呢，对吧？”（你知道的）它只会持续一会儿，（你知道的）但后来我花更多时间与患者相处，尤其是那些治疗抵抗型患者、最终不得不做手术的患者。我很快从轶事的角度了解到，自杀倾向在PMDD中非常普遍。最可怕的事情之一
about it is that they really feel like a different person. You know, it's very severe, dark depression during that time for some of these folks. And then when they come, out of it, there's almost an identity disturbance of now I feel completely normal and happy, who am I? What was that? Right. And it's very scary for them. And often they don't want to talk about how dark it gets when they're feeling fine, which is completely understandable. But all of this contributes a little bit, I think, to us not fully understanding the severity. So what we did, we did a global survey through the International Association of Pre-Mensual Disorders, where I volunteer, they did a global survey of the people who utilized their services and their information online.
关于它的是，他们真的觉得自己像变了个人。（你知道的）在其中的某些时期，这些患者会经历非常严重、黑暗的抑郁。然后当他们从那种状态中走出来时，几乎会产生一种身份认同的混乱：现在我感觉完全正常和快乐了，我是谁？那是什么？对吧。这让他们感到非常害怕。而且通常当他们感觉良好的时候，他们不愿意谈论那种黑暗感，这是完全可以理解的。但我认为，所有这些都在一定程度上导致了我们未能充分理解其严重性。所以我们所做的是，通过国际经前期障碍协会（我在这里做志愿者）进行了一次全球调查，他们对利用其服务和在线信息的群体进行了全球调查。
And they asked people a lot of questions about whether they'd been diagnosed, how they'd been diagnosed. And so we took a sampling of people who had been diagnosed through daily ratings by some kind of health care provider. So it's not a perfect diagnostic gaining system, but it's pretty good. And so then we took those 600 people and we asked them about lifetime experiences of suicidal thoughts and behaviors. And what we found in those 600 patients with PMDD, we found that 72% reported active thoughts of suicidal ideation in their lifetime. 49% reported lifetime experiences of planning a suicide attempt. 42% reported having had intention to make a suicide attempt at some point. 40% had actually started to prepare for an attempt at some point,
他们向人们询问了许多关于是否被确诊以及如何被确诊的问题。因此，我们抽取了一部分通过某种医疗保健提供者的每日评分确诊的样本。所以这不是一个完美的诊断获取系统，但它相当不错。然后我们询问了这600人关于一生中自杀想法和行为的经历。我们在那600名PMDD患者中发现，72%的人报告一生中有过积极的自杀意念活动；49%的人报告一生中有过策划自杀尝试的经历；42%的人报告曾在某个时刻有过实施自杀尝试的意图；40%的人在某个时刻实际上已经开始为自杀尝试做准备，
and 34% had actually made a suicide attempt across their lifetime. So these are really quite striking high numbers. And when we co-varied other diagnoses that the patient had received, this did not account for their symptoms. So it really seems that pre-meltrial dysphoric disorder is associated with suicidal thoughts and behaviors. And then at the same time, my laboratory also does work recruiting general psychiatric patients with menstrual cycles who have suicidal thoughts to try to understand when we don't select for people who say that they're having these hormone-sensitive menstrual cycle symptoms. do we still see them in those with suicidal thoughts? Among just sort of a general psychiatric sample who menstruate that have suicidal thoughts, what role does the menstrual cycle play?
并且34%的人在一生中实际实施过自杀尝试。所以这些确实是相当惊人的高数字。当我们把患者获得的其他人诊断作为协变量进行调整时，这并不能解释他们的症状。因此，经前期烦躁症确实似乎与自杀想法和行为相关。与此同时，我的实验室还开展了一项工作，招募有月经周期的、有自杀想法的普通精神科患者，以试图了解：当我们不特意挑选那些说自己有这些激素敏感性月经周期症状的人时，我们在有自杀想法的人群中是否依然能看到这些症状？在仅仅是一般有月经的精神科样本中，如果他们有自杀想法，月经周期扮演了什么角色？
And what we see is that it is pretty consistently 50 to 60% of our sample that has significant cyclical changes in mood and suicidality. And so it really seems that that's a much higher number than the 6% in the general population with pretty, menstrual changes. And so it really does seem that, you know, when you recruit for PMDD, you get suicidality. When you recruit for suicidality, you get PMDD. You get those hormone sensitive cycle changes. So we're still trying to understand exactly why that is. My laboratory does clinical trials to try to probe and understand, especially in those suicidal populations, what is the role of different
而我们看到的是，在我们的样本中，有50%到60%的人相当稳定地表现出情绪和自杀倾向的显著周期性变化。所以这确实看起来是一个远高于普通人群中6%（有明显经期变化者）的数字。因此，确实看起来（你知道的）当你招募PMDD患者时，你会发现自杀倾向；当你招募自杀倾向患者时，你会发现PMDD。你会发现那些激素敏感的周期变化。所以我们仍在努力确切理解这是为什么。我的实验室正在进行临床试验，试图探究和理解，特别是在那些有自杀倾向的人群中，不同的
hormone dynamics in provoking acute suicide risk. But we have a long way to go to really bring all of this together and understand how this develops over time and what role the hormone sensitivity plays. Let's talk for a minute about people who are assigned male at birth. Do they have the same sensitivity to hormones as people who are assigned female at birth? Is it similar? Yeah, so I'm not an expert in sex differences in the brain overall, but my understanding is that there really isn't a lot of evidence for a male brain or a female brain. And it really is a lot more complex than that. And I think that that's likely to be true in this case as well.
激素动力学在引发急性自杀风险中起什么作用。但我们要真正将这一切结合起来，理解它是如何随时间发展的以及激素敏感性发挥了什么作用，还有很长的路要走。让我们花一分钟谈谈那些出生时被指定为男性的人。他们是否和出生时被指定为女性的人一样对激素敏感？它相似吗？是的，所以虽然我并不是大脑中性别差异的整体专家，但我的理解是，其实并没有很多证据支持所谓的“男性大脑”或“女性大脑”。它实际上要复杂得多。我认为这种情况很可能也适用于此。
Unfortunately, there has been very little research on how those assigned male at birth react to similar estrogen and progesterone changes in the brain. Of course, the upshot is that those assigned male at birth generally don't have menstrual, cycles. They don't have menstrual cycles. And so they're not going to be exposed to these fluctuations on the same time scale. And so even if they did have, you know, again, if the brain is sort of similar in many ways between males and females, you would expect that there's probably a similar percentage of males who would react the same way if we were to induce sort of a menstrual cycle in them. But this is a little bit less of less public.
不幸的是，关于出生时被指定为男性的人如何对大脑中类似的雌激素和孕激素变化做出反应的研究非常少。当然，结果就是出生时被指定为男性的人通常没有月经周期。他们没有月经周期。因此，他们不会在相同的时间尺度上暴露于这些波动中。所以即使他们确实有（当然，如果男性和女性的大脑在很多方面在某种程度上是相似的），你也会预期，如果我们给他们诱导某种月经周期，可能有相似比例的男性会做出同样的反应。但这受到的公开关注
interest in the sense that they're not likely to experience those changes. And so it's a little bit of an artificial proof of concept, right? One thing I will say is that Peter Schmidt at NIH, the wonderful scientist, who leads the behavioral endocrinology branch, he has done, I believe, one experimental study that did provide some support that some males are sensitive to normal testosterone changes. And so there is, I think there's, there's no reason to think that males wouldn't have much of the same possible hormone sensitivity. It's just that in general, testosterone doesn't have a monthly cycle, right? It may change for other reasons, and that very well may provoke symptoms at some time points in males. But again, because of the fluctuations being
较少，因为他们不太可能经历这些变化。所以这有点像一个概念上的非人工证明，对吧？我要说的一点是，NIH的Peter Schmidt是一位出色的科学家，他领导着行为内分泌学分部，据我所知，他做过一项实验研究，确实为部分男性对正常睾酮变化敏感提供了一些支持。因此我认为，没有理由认为男性不会拥有很大一部分相同的潜在激素敏感性。只是总的来说，睾酮并没有一个月的周期，对吧？它可能会因为其他原因而改变，这很可能会在某些时间点引发男性的症状。但同样，由于波动
less regular, it ends up being less of less interest from a public health standpoint. I do think that one thing that would be interesting to study is that we know that the ovaries are not the only source of progesterone. The adrenals also produce progesterone, especially in response to stress. And so it does seem possible that, you know, perhaps there could be a stress-related episode of hormone sensitivity in both men and women. I think that's, been a little bit understudied. And I think that, you know, that's something that could be very interesting. Well, to wrap up, I want to go back to my introduction when I talked about the history of using the menstrual cycle to justify stereotypes of women as being emotional and irrational.
不太规律，从公共卫生的角度来看，它最终受到的关注较少。我认为有一件值得研究的事情是，我们知道卵巢并不是孕激素的唯一来源。肾上腺也会产生孕激素，特别是在应对压力时。因此，确实有可能（你知道的）男性和女性都可能存在与压力相关的激素敏感性发作。我认为这方面的研究还稍显不足。并且我认为（你知道的）那可能是一件非常有趣的事情。好吧，作为总结，我想回到我的引言，当时我谈到了利用月经周期来证明女性情绪化和非理性这一刻板印象的历史。
What can researchers do to study the menstrual cycle without contributing to those stereotypes? It's a fantastic question. I think it's very important to abandon the idea of studying the effects of the menstrual cycle on behavior as a general concept. We need to study individual differences in reactivity to the menstrual cycle. So if we want to understand, for example, the effects of the menstrual cycle on anxiety, we need to select a sample of people who have cyclical changes in anxiety versus people who do not. Because otherwise, if you think about it, if only 6% of the population has cyclical changes in emotional symptoms, and only some of those people have cyclical changes in anxiety,
研究人员能做些什么来研究月经周期，而又不会助长这些刻板印象？这是一个极好的问题。我认为非常重要的一点是，抛弃将研究月经周期对行为的影响作为一个一般概念的想法。我们需要研究对月经周期的反应性的个体差异。因此，如果我们想要了解，例如，月经周期对焦虑的影响，我们需要选择一组在焦虑方面具有周期性变化的人，与没有这种变化的人进行对比。因为否则的话，如果你仔细想想，如果只有6%的人口有情绪症状的周期性变化，并且只有其中一部分人有焦虑的周期性变化，
you're really looking at a very small percentage of the population that's going to show the type of changes that you're interested in understanding. And so it really behooves us to select a hormone-sensitive sample, and usually we do this by collecting daily ratings at the beginning to try to really select people who are, showing some kind of change in the construct that we're interested in, and then diving into how those people differ from people who don't have the symptoms. So I really think that this assumption that the menstrual cycle has a standard effect on any kind of behavior probably needs to end.
你实际上是在观察极小比例的人口，他们会表现出你有兴趣了解的那种变化类型。因此，我们确实有责任选择一个激素敏感的样本，通常我们通过在一开始收集每日评分来做到这一点，以真正挑选出那些表现出我们感兴趣的结构某种变化的人，然后深入探讨这些人与没有这些症状的人有何不同。所以我真的认为，月经周期对任何行为都有标准影响的这种假设可能需要结束了。
Well, and on that note, I want to thank you so much for joining me today, Dr. Eisenhower-Mell. This has been very interesting. Thank you. Thank you so much for having me. You can read more about psychologists' research on hormones and mental health in the September issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. To read it, go to www.apa.org slash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a comment or a review.
好吧，借此机会，我要非常感谢你今天加入我们，Eisenhower-Mell博士。这非常有趣。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。你可以在APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）9月号上阅读更多关于心理学家对激素和心理健康研究的了解。要阅读它，请访问 www.apa.org/monitor。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取喜爱播客的任何地方，找到往期的《心理学之声》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评论或评分。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。